ahora nos piden compara 156.3 78 con 156
punto 3 48 y lo que haremos primero es
reescribir estos números
aquí cientos 56.378 que compararemos con
156 puntos
para algunos ya puede ser muy obvio muy
evidente cuál de estos dos números es
más grande sin embargo iremos paso a
paso en caso de que para alguien no sea
aún tan obvio así es que lo que haremos
es el valor posicional del más grande
hacia el más pequeño para ver cuáles son
las diferencias y a partir de ello
determinar cuál es más grande
empezaremos en el valor posicional de
las centenas porque aquí porque aquí
este uno representa 100 por el valor
posicional está en las centenas es una
centena son 100 unidades y representa
mucho más que si lo colocamos tal vez en
el lugar de las decenas o de las
unidades aquí representado aquí
representa 100 10 o 1 así es que
empecemos en el valor posicional más
grande
tenemos en la centenas 1 ó 100 esto
representa un 100 y 1
tenemos entonces el mismo valor hasta el
momento son iguales en las decenas
tenemos 55 x 1050 este 5 nos representa
50 unidades
y en el número de abajo también tenemos
5 vamos exactamente igual nos recorremos
al siguiente valor posicional que en
este caso son las unidades tenemos 6
unidades en este número y 6 unidades en
el de abajo 6 por 1 realmente vamos
exactamente igual entramos en el terreno
de los decimales y veamos
en el lugar de las décimas tenemos tres
en el número de arriba y tres en el
número de abajo
si nos vamos a las centésimas tendremos
siete en el número de arriba y cuatro en
el número de abajo aquí ya tenemos una
diferencia que nos indica que este
número en los centésimos es mayor tiene
7 centésimos mientras aquí sólo tenemos
4 y medidas todavía faltan números
tenemos un 8 a la derecha así y ahí no
importa que estos números fueran
diferentes este incluso pudo haber sido
más grande pero no importa porque el
valor posicional mayor que es el de los
centésimos en este caso ya marca una
diferencia donde se indica que el número
de arriba es más grande
así es que escribamos que 156.3 78 es
mayor que 156 punto 3 48
y en específico se debe en este caso a
los centésimos
donde el 7 es mayor que este 4